i have seen on the interwebs on the tick  tocks that you can color correct your  teeth  now what does that mean well they're  saying that you can use purple to cancel  out the yellow on your teeth i mean  color wheel wise it makes sense but we  gotta test it we're gonna make a  homemade recipe today so let's get into  it first i need a little baby cup this  tupperware will do next baking soda i  don't have any exact measurements that  looks good next up on the list  food dye now i've been told to use  looking at my notes i've been told to  use 12 drops of red and eight drops of  blue to make purple this seems way more  blue than it does red i might add a  little bit more red  it seems very  blue i'm gonna go brush my teeth with it  so apparently  you're just supposed to dip your  toothbrush in  and get to brushing i'm scared  no i've been lied to